Rob Schneider: Hey, thanks buddy but you forgot to put me in Pixels.
Adam Sandler: Well that's because you wouldn't do Blackface for me.
Rob Schneider: Seriously Sandler, even I have standards.
Adam Sandler: No you don't.
Rob Schneider: You're right.
Past Sandler Character: No Adam, Don't you see?
Even your idiot characters from the past have figured it out.
Your audience has grown up but you yourself have not grown up.
Adam Sandler: What are you talking about dude? I've got a lot older.
Past Sandler character: No Adam! Your audience have discovered new things so you must discover new things.
Evolve your craft. Try something different.
Use your movies as more than just an excuse to go on vacation.
I mean look at your latest publicity photo, even you're sick of you.
Try again Adam Sandler. Try!
Adam Sandler: I see what you're saying.
I should be even more predictable...
Past Sandler character: Well erm, no...
Adam Sandler: More unfunny...
Past Sandler character: I definitely didn't say that.
Adam Sandler: And even more racially insensitive.
Past Sandler Character: Oh Christ, I'm just going to sit down.
Adam Sandler: Hey Rob Schneider, can you do Redface?
Rob Schneider: [Enthusiastically] Can I?
[INTRO MUSIC PLAYS]
[INTRO MUSIC FADES]
Nostalgia Critic: Hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic, I remember it so you don't have to.
Well ever since I did my clip-less review of "Jurassic World"
a lot of people have been requesting me to do another recent movie
and surprisingly it wasn't "50 Shades of Grey."
Tamara: Thank God!
Nostalgia Critic: Hey, come on, ball gags are surprisingly comfortable.
Tamara: How would you know?
Nostalgia Critic: Research.
No, that movie is the Adam Sandler non-hit, "Pixels".
Left and right people have been asking me to review this and at first, I didn't really get why.
Okay there is nostalgic value seeing how it ties into video games of the eighties
and I have ripped apart several Adam Sandler productions of the past
but I think the real reason is, it's one of the worst reviewed films of the year.
The internet has gone insane with how much they hate this movie.
It's this year's "Fantastic Four".
I mean...before this year's "Fantastic Four".
Yeah it looked bad but...seventeen percent bad?
That's lower than "Waterboy", "That's My Boy", and "Little Nicky".
Jesus, it's worse than those!?
That's like having Hitler and then finding out that there's a mega Hitler.
A Hitler that did even worse than Hitler and wasn't funny.
So without further ado, let's take a look at...
O.C: Futurama.
Animated Elephant: Futurama, Futurama, Futurama, Futurama, Futurama, Futurama...
Nostalgia Critic: Yes, let's first address what everybody is already talking about
How similar this concept is to an episode of "Futurama".
Despite the movie being based on a short film, there's an episode of "Futurama" where video games from the 80's
attack their city that's pretty damn close in comparison to this.
But I'm choosing to judge this on its own merits because much like "Osmosis Jones" and "Inside Out",
Even if it has been done it before, what matters is what they can bring to it that's new and good.
And Adam Sandler Movies are so the exact opposite of this that there is actually an app for it now.
Animated Elephant: There is?
Nostalgia Critic: Oh yeah, it's called the "Appler Sandler".
His films are actually so easy to make now that you can literally phone them in.
Err, let's see, Normal voice Sandler or Annoying voice Sandler?
Animated Elephant: I'd rather rub my balls on a cheese grater than listen to his annoying voice.
Nostalgia Critic: Normal voice it is.
Err, let's see, bland, hot girlfriend or really bland, hot girlfriend?
Animated Elephant: What's the difference?
Nostalgia Critic: One gets a crying scene.
Animated Elephant: Hmm, I guess that one.
Nostalgia Critic: You got it.
Animated Elephant: Wait, what are those?
Nostalgia Critic: Oh, those are add-ons that come no matter what.
Kevin James, Suckered in Celebrities, Pitty cameos from SNL Alumni.
The only thing left to choose is funny or unfunny?
Animated Elephant: Oh my God I never knew we had a choice. Choose funny man.
Nostalgia Critic: Alright.
Hey, what the....
...come on.
Animated Elephant: Come on.
Nostalgia Critic: Jesus Christ, why would you put so much time, effort and money into something
if you're clearly not going to make it funny, you painfully obvious metaphor.
Animated Elephant: [Annoyed sigh]
Nostalgia Critic: It starts off with the younger versions of Adam Sandler and Kevin James in an arcade competition,
Where we insert Sandler App number 162, "Sweet Old Lady", who delivers our first big zinger.
Tamara: "Look it's Grandma."
Malcolm:  "Yoohoo."
[Pause button sound effect]
Nostalgia Critic: That's the first joke people, she says "Yoohoo" while holding up a bottle of "Yoohoo".
A $110 Million Dollar budget and that is their opening joke.
You know, why don't you just be honest and say...
Tamara: Look, it's Grandma...
Malcolm: F*ck you bitches, I'm smoking your money.
Nostalgia Critic: Sandler loses to a kid named Eddie
which means that Eddie's gameplay will be put in a time capsule and launched into space
This brings us to present day when Sandler App number 229,
"Down on his luck has-been who people think will amount to nothing"
is having a conversation with Sandler App 465, "Supportive best friend and binge drinking idiot Kevin James",
who is President of the United States.
[Alarms]
[Phone Explodes]
Yep, even the app couldn't handle something that dumb. Kevin James is President of the United States.
Exploded phone: Bullshit.
Nostalgia Critic: In a country that is actually kind of considering electing Donald Trump as our next president,
Even we can't be f*cking stupid enough to accept this as a reality.
And the weird thing is, he still plays it as the idiot best friend like he always does.
He doesn't act like a president at all.
Which is why, just to give you an idea about how lazy this is, I'm going to switch out Kevin James with Obama.
Now tell me if this makes any sense whatsoever,
Obama: Now Adam...
Sandler: Er, Burnie, please. I'm a totally different character now.
Obama:  Yeah sure, so Adam, I'd like to get drunk while helping my loser friend in a bar
but I, err, need to overcome this outburst I had whilst screaming at school children because I can't read.
Sandler: That's really in our movie?
Obama: That's really in our movie.
Sandler: Shouldn't you be doing presidential stuff, that kind of thing?
Obama: Oh I do, like when our country is under attack I make a cake with my wife.
Sandler: That can't be in our movie.
Obama: Page twenty two.
Sandler: That's in our movie.
Obama: I'll give you a call when I'll need you to replace our military.
Sandler: If you're still in the Theatre folks  I, err,  salute ya.
Nostalgia Critic: Sandler then goes to a customer's house to fix their TV but finds the owner, played by Michelle Monaghan,
is crying in the closet while sipping champagne out of a sippy cup.
Yeah, a sippy cup.
Sandler: Oh, is that your kid's?
Monaghan: No, he's 12.
Sandler: Then why do you have...?
Monaghan: [Gasp} How dare you? I can never see us becoming a couple ever. Ever!
[Pause Sound Effect]
Nostalgia Critic: Okay, who is the fucking idiot who keeps falling for this?
The couple that act like they're not going to get together but everyone else in the world knows they're going to get together.
Who's the one f*cking idiot who keeps falling for this and encourages this cliché?
[Missiles explode nervous, wavering hand]
Thank you, there is one less in the world.
But he is called to the White House as Sandler App 143 takes place of a "Huge Romantic Coincidence"
That Monaghan happens to be Lieutenant Colonel.
Insert "Saved by the Bell" commercial here.
[Saved By the Bell interlude music plays]
Obama: Hey, hey, we're not done yet. We're not done yet.
Now Adam,  our military was attacked in a way that was, err, very similar to a video game.
As you know, no-one in our American Intelligence has ever played a video game.
Sandler: Yeah, nerds and games often don't mix.
Obama: You are the only person who can figure out these patterns that people online have figured out years ago.
I personally only watch "PewDiePie", never touched a video game in my life.
Nostalgia Critic: You know I'd like to keep listening but I just want to,
"Emphasize more what a gosh, darn, great, misunderstood guy, Sandler is."
We need a bully, ah, let's see here...
Jock,
Snob,
Business man,
Popular Kid,
Oooo, old curmudgeon Brian Cox.
[Inaudible gibberish]
Hmm, I can't understand his one-dimensional dialogue but thankfully there is a feature
where you can just insert all the bully dialogue from all his other movies.
Automated Voice:  You're a loser and weird. You are different from us which makes you bad.
Your marching to a different drum will lead no-where. Now get out of here you puppy eyed dreamer.
Before I hammer in some more how wrong I am and how beautiful you are.
[Inaudible gibberish]
Nostalgia Critic: But don't worry, we can't see Sandler as too much of a loser so the app comes with,
"Unrealistic over-compensatingingly pathetic best friend."
And I know that it's the actor who played the snowman from "Frozen" and not the actual snowman from "Frozen"
but I'm choosing him because the only funny thing they have in common is that you want to see them both impaled.
Sandler: Whoa, aren't you that perverted kid from my past?
Olaf: Yup, I spent 30 years wishing a video game character would come to life and make love to me.
Sandler: Ah, just like my fanbase.
Olaf: Now lets teach them that sitting on your lazy ass, playing video games can somehow make you a hero.
Sandler: I think this calls for some inane gibberish...
[Inane gibberish]
Nostalgia Critic: So the aliens misinterpret the time capsule and think it's an act of war.
Therefore, Sandler and Unfunny Pervert instruct the soldiers about how to defeat them.
But of course when they finally attack, nobody listens.
Sandler: No, no, you're supposed to shoot all the way to the left.
Automated voice: Do not listen to him even though we are supposed to.
We are military and not trained to follow orders.
Nostalgia Critic: But Sandler grabs a gun and starts shooting them up like an action hero.
Because playing this at home is clearly the same thing as fighting in the field.
And he kills them all off, proving that Adam Sandler is in fact better than the military.
Automated Voice: Most unorthodox.
Nostalgia Critic: This calls for a party where the president chugs the Hell out of everybody.
Monaghan: Um, Mr President, don't you think we should try communicating with the aliens to negotiate out of any further trouble.
Obama, No, now is the time to chug beer, being the overweight, rambunctious white man that I am.
Nostalgia Critic: Again, I took some liberties here.
Obama: It's my job to go and take "Kennedy" on this beer.
Chorus: Overweight white man, overweight white man...
Chorus: Overweight white man...
Nostalgia Critic: But knowing another threat is on the way,
They call in Eddie, the gaming champion from years ago, played now by Peter Dinklage.
Only, seeing as how he is in a Sandler movie all his talent has to be "Shyamalized".
In reverse.
Shyamalan: Huh?
Dinklage: Huh?
Nostalgia Critic: Okay, look. You know how in a Shyamalan film you take something that's not funny and you make it funny?
Shyamalan: Yeah.
Nostalgia Critic: Well in an Adam Sandler movie you take something that's funny and you make it not funny.
Shyamalan: Oh, thanks buddy.
Nostalgia Critic: Ooo, the app also allows the uncomfortable moment of silence
that follows every unfunny joke that is never filled with laughter.
Dinklage: Whores, peeing and farts.
Nostalgia Critic: Draw it out, Happy Maddison still thinks the audience is laughing at this.
...
..........................
Shyamalan: Christ, this is too awkward, even for me
and I'm Shyamalan.
[Interlude music plays]
Nostalgia Critic: So the final challenge is chasing Pac-Man in the city as,
Sandler, Pervert and Dinklage represents the Ghosts in cars as Monaghan advises them from the sidelines.
Okay, why in this universe, does being good at Pac-Man suddenly translate into being good at driving?
Would you really trust your fate in the hands of Pervert T' Fro-man?
Olaf: I'm funny because I don't make you laugh.
Nostalgia Critic: Wouldn't it make more sense if the Lieutenant Colonel, the one that's been in the field was driving,
and Sandler's men, the people that just been watching on a screen were advising?
Wouldn't that just add up more?
Sandler: Na, na, you don't want that because I've got to be the hero. So you can't really take it that seriously.
Nostalgia Critic: But the reason that doesn't work Sandler is because you act like you're taking it so seriously.
Like, look at the scene after you defeat Pac-Man.
You're clearly supposed to feel for this romance because it goes on for f*cking ever and there's no laughs.
If you want to go full silly, fine, then leave out the serious romance,
leave out the generic bully,
leave out the complicated rules you're making up for this world because they clearly don't make any sense.
These are so poorly written, we can't tell when you're supposed to be funny or supposed to be real.
Sandler: No, no, no it's okay, there is a special feature on the app
that lets you know when you're supposed to take me seriously and when you're not.
It's actually a musical app. Yeah, you listen to the music and it lets you know
because I've actually heard it so many times my personality actually kind of changes along with it.
[Sad Music plays]
Sandler: I don't know if she'll ever love me. Maybe we're just meant to be apart.
[Inspiring Upbeat Music Plays]
Come on Guys, we're going to go get my girlfriend back.
[Soft sensual music plays]
Who said I was flirting? I didn't say I was flirting?
[Jovial plot moving forward music plays]
I'm going to win the championship and save Grandma.
Huh, so music to tell us how to feel.
Dinklage: Does that mean you're finally going to give me a funny line?
Sandler: Don't ever ask me that again Dinklage.
Nostalgia Critic: But the alien claimed that Earth cheated, not playing by the video game rules
and unleash all their pixellated characters on the world.
Monaghan: How did this happen?
Dinklage: I can answer that.
I entered the cheat code to teleport my car in the last challenge like I did years ago to beat you.
Monaghan: Wait, can I take this one?
Okay.
Are you f*cking kidding me?
No seriously, are you f*cking kidding me?
First of all, how did you enter a cheat code at a championship?
Did none of the hundreds of people there see you enter it?
Second of all, where did you enter it? Your f*cking car? Did you have a control panel on your wheel?
Or did you just honk f*cking Morse code at them?
Third of all, how the f*ck did you teleport your car? This is real life!
You can't teleport your car or enter cheat codes in real life!
We all said yes to this script. We wanted our names on this.
Could, can we just like hug it out a bit? I just need to know that we're going to survive all of this.
Sandler: Sure, sure.
Monaghan: Okay.
Sandler: It's okay.
Obama: Hey, look everyone! I'm doing the robot instead of responding appropriately to hostile alien life.
Chorus: Overweight white man, overweight white man...
Chorus: Overweight white man...
Obama: Yep, do the R-Obama.
Nostalgia Critic: And now we reach the part of the app that nears the end of every Adam Sandler movie.
Giving up.
Yep, they just give up.
You know how in most movie climaxes that's where they try their hardest, well here, that's where they try their least.
In fact, there's even a game on the app that's simply entitled,
"The Lazier the Writer, The Faster the Paycheck"
This is where you add up how many times the writer clearly didn't give a shit
and just wrote down anything he wanted to get his pay cheque a little faster.
Let's take a look.
The aliens gave several trophies earlier, one of them being Q*bert
and only now, several days later, think to ask him anything about their alien race.
Sandler: So what's the history of your species as you watch me win "Call of Duty"? Eh, Doody.
Nostalgia Critic: The aliens attack full force with all the pixellated characters which is neat
but they make it clear that when they touch something it turns into pixels
but when a crane stops Frogger, nothing happens.
But really, who gives a shit when the president comes out and says this,
Obama: They wanted to put me in a bunker. I said no thanks.
Instead I'm going to fight video game aliens and err, save the world.
[Pause sound effect]
Nostalgia Critic: Actually, that would be pretty cool if Obama really did that.
But he didn't, it was Kevin James. Put him back in there.
Kevin James: Yay, your president, Paul Blart is going to shoot up aliens.
Someone give me a beer to chug.
[Pause sound effect]
Nostalgia Critic: Now that's the stupidity I'm used to.
It's like independence day only that was hilarious and this isn't.
Unfunny pervert's video game character he fantasized over comes to life.
Except she's not pixel-ly, she looks just like a real person.
There is no reason for this.
Oh yeah, and despite her not talking at all, she also falls in love with the unfunny pervert.
There is again, no reason for this.
Animated "writer": The less I try, the closer my money gets to me.
Nostalgia Critic: So the aliens send a CG Max Headroom, that somehow looks even more fake than the original Max Headroom.
to summon our heroes for one last challenge. Again, really no reason at all to give them a chance to win.
But once again they have to play by the games rules so what do our heroes do?
They cheat and don't play by the games rules.
Yeah, remember that scene earlier saying how cheating was bad?
Well that is exactly what they do, except it ends up winning the day.
The only reason it's okay here is because it makes Adam Sandler look good.
Animated "writer": Less talking, I'm almost rewarded for my incredible gift.
Nostalgia Critic: This means all the pixels disappear including unfunny perv's love but it's okay because Q*bert turns into her.
This is so blatantly lazy that even Sandler himself shrugs off how little this makes sense but doesn't give a shit.
Sandler: Nobody questions why Q*bert suddenly turned into a hot lady?
Oh well, who cares? We just wasted millions of dollars and doomed video game movies forever. Whoa!
Animated "writer": I did it, I half-assed what thousands of writers have tried years to do for a living. Yay!
Announcer Voice: And to preserve our comedic masterpiece, we're taking down every video on Vimeo that has the word "Pixels" in the title.
Yes, we really did that. We're kind of f*cking insane.
Oh, and while we're at it.
We know what you want, we're so not behind the times.
And that was "Pixels", one of the most hated films of the year.
Is it one of the worst, if not, the worst Adam Sandler production that has ever been put together?
No.
It's not even close really.
There are so many other films that he has had a hand in that tried less and accomplished less than this has.
There was one or two neat effects and every twenty minutes maybe I had a little bit of a laugh
which is more than I can say for some of his other productions.
So, why is there so much hate? Why does this one get people just so f*cking pissed off?
Because it's 20 f*cking 15.
The fact that Sandler is still using these lazy gimmicks with no changes is just becoming insulting.
Even if you don't like his humour which is totally understandable, you felt like he was at least trying.
You felt like, even though it was weird there was some form of effort being put into his work before.
Here it's like a $110 million dollar auto-pilot.
We know Sandler, as well as all the people here can be both talented and funny.
But as so many comedians are trying to evolve and adapt with the time
Sandler seems bizarrely disinterested in getting better.
I think we're angry because we want to like "Pixels". We want to like Sandler's work
and when we find, it's not only bad but feels uncaring-ly bad,
we wonder why no-one is waking up after all of these bombs and saying, lets try something different.
Let's step up our game, step up our jokes, step up our characters.
This is the tipping point where people are just saying, "Enough is Enough."
"Give us effort again, give us energy, give us something that feels fresh and new."
"Similar to the first surreal time that we've ever encountered you."
Until then, we still have the Sandler App
and hopefully there will be a day where this will no longer be a requirement in any of his films.
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and...
Come back.
Animated Elephant: I never left.
Nostalgia Critic: Not you.
Animated Elephant: Hmm.
Adam Sandler: What the Hell happened to me?
I used to be the Clown Prince of comedy.
I used to say, "They're all going to laugh at you."
And now I'm just praying that you'll laugh at me.
[Inane gibberish]
Kevin James: Yay, your president, Paul Blart is going to shoot up aliens.